at a protest in london natalia is
surrounded by family and wrapped in the
flag of her country
but her mind is elsewhere
my mom and my stepdad were leaving sumi
and uh for the last two days the sumi
just been bombed and unseriously shelled
and people can't even escape because the
town is surrounded now so there is
nowhere to go and and
even if it's even if it's a chance for
them to escape actually quite a lot of
people don't want to go they say we will
stand there until
until we can
natalia's mother is in sumi a town 40
kilometers from ukraine's northeast
border russian forces have been shelling
it for days
my mom actually texted me saying
they bomb it again and i've signed up to
this sumi group that's getting update
and i could see that uh
there was a the the warning of the siren
and uh i still last voice had been two
hours i'm still waiting to hear back
from my mum to see if well she's alive
basically yeah
and to be fair that's pretty much how me
and my family that's how we have been
for a week now or i don't even know how
many days it just seems to be just this
one horrible day that every evening i
say good night and goodbye to her and
every morning we just wake up and hope
and she'll answer again
it seems everyone here has a reason to
pray
just yesterday i was uh i was on a call
with
my grandparents and uh
our call was stopped by uh by sirens
so
i mean so far they haven't started
bombing there anything but um in the uh
in the east um
so far i mean
they're they're relatively all right
compared to you know anybody on the
front lines i've heard that women are
separated from their
kids men are left back to fight for the
country
and this just really
brings burden to my heart
footwol stood together too
the premier league and its clubs calling
for peace
a loud and united message across all of
football sadia chowdhury sky news in
london